the importance of wealth in our
economies and the inequality of that
wealth have been going up for decades
but the tax revenue raised from that
wealth has not followed suit
so i think politicians facing pressure
on their public finances are missing a
trick
and that trick is an annual levy on the
total wealth of taxpayers
[Music]
welcome to free lunch on film the series
where i explore controversial economic
policy ideas that i find appealing such
as an annual wealth tax
so if you create a tax system that taxes
the rich efficiently then i'll be happy
to give it away i think it would be an
awful idea what we're really talking
about is not a wealth tax but a
punishment tax of some kind they are
complicated to administer and haven't
raised much revenue the thing it can do
that no other tax on wealth can do is to
reduce wealth inequality at the very top
in the last 40 years wealth and capital
have become much more important in rich
economies
the total amount of wealth has gone from
about three times annual national income
to more than six times
and this larger amount of wealth is now
distributed more unevenly than it used
to
in many countries owners of capital now
receive a larger share of national
income than earlier and workers a
smaller share
for that reason some of the very rich
think that they should pay a wealth tax
like gary stevenson
born in east london he became citibank's
top trader he now campaigns for pressure
group patriotic millionaires so i came
to the conclusion that we had a
structural problem inequality it
wouldn't get fixed which means that
there would never be an econ recovery
and i started betting on that and by the
end of that year i was citibank's most
profitable trader in the world
so um
you know i've spent a lot of time
thinking about this um i think that if
you don't fix inequality
the economy will get worse and worse and
worse and worse and i'm from a poor
background there's people from where i'm
from like my friends like my family like
me growing up that are bearing the brunt
of that
and yet many governments have moved away
from directly taxing this growing wealth
until the 1990s about a dozen european
countries levied a net wealth tax and
one by one they got rid of it like here
in france
when emmanuel macron became president in
2017 one of his first acts was to
abolish the country's net wealth tax
for his opponents that branded him as
the president of the rich
for his supporters it ushered in a new
era of french business dynamism
the idea of
repealing the wealth tax was
to make france more competitive and
attractive to entrepreneurs
sarah perry an economist at the oecd
think tank has looked hard at the pros
and cons of a wealth tax
they are unusual today there are only
three oecd countries that currently levy
annual wealth taxes and those countries
are
norway spain and switzerland
it's not that other countries don't tax
wealth at all
we have many taxes that could be called
wealth taxes in a broad sense my critics
will point out that you're taxed when
you buy a house or when you inherit or
on capital gains when you sell an asset
to name just a few examples
marin somerset webb is an investment
columnist for the ft
we don't call them wealth taxes but they
are wealth taxes you can disagree with
them or agree with them as you like and
i think that they're very flawed but
nonetheless they do something that makes
sense which is that they ask people to
hand over money at the point at which
they have money at a point of
transaction
so what is a wealth tax proper
a net wealth tax is a tax on the net
wealth of individuals so assets minus
debts
and it's usually levied on only certain
individuals above a certain threshold of
wealth so it doesn't apply to everybody
and the important part as well is that
it's a recurrent tax we're talking about
annual wealth taxes so the base on which
a net wealth tax would be levied
includes all the wealth somebody owns
property obviously also financial wealth
such as bank deposits shares bonds
but also valuables like art and jewelry
fine wine and classic cars
and ownership stakes in private
businesses
from all that you would deduct the debts
somebody owes a mortgage on their house
car loans
money they may have borrowed to invest
and finally you would deduct a tax-free
allowance
and with all of that you would arrive at
the taxable wealth on which an annual
rate would be levied
so for example the you know some people
in the top one percent of wealth they're
people who have more than two million
pounds in wealth so if say you had two
and a half million pounds in wealth and
you had a one percent annual wealth tax
then you'd be paying one percent on the
bit of wealth you have above two million
that half a million so someone at two
and a half million pounds would be
paying about five thousand pounds a year
and the list of taxable assets could go
on
private jets pension plans trusts horses
intellectual property
so at a time of increasing demands on
public finance
is a wealth tax worth considering
most economists and tax experts are
skeptical as are many of my ft
colleagues most countries who've tried
this find that it doesn't work so i mean
i'm sometimes amused we're still having
a conversation about it
but especially after the pandemic some
experts think it's an option we should
at least look into
pandemic was awful for almost everybody
you know lots of people were getting
into debt and at the top end you just
see wealth continue to rise continue to
explode and i think that's one of the
reasons that people have then really
been thinking well how are we taxing
this wealth why aren't we getting more
money from the people who in some sense
really have the broader shoulders
aaron advani co-chaired an independent
commission of academics in the uk
which ended up backing a one-off wealth
tax
from an economic point of view i think
attacks like this at the very top end
yeah is very sensible
and sarah pereira says it is becoming a
live issue and not just in europe
so the most
prominent example was the us where
wealth taxes were a big part of the
debate in the democratic primaries but
there's also been discussions in some
latin american countries chile
is one argentina introduced a one-off
wealth tax
during the pandemic
so let's go through the arguments for
and against
first the basic function of taxes is to
raise revenue for the government
so how much could a wealth tax bring in
potentially
it could raise significant amounts of
revenue and not only that but from a
limited number of very wealthy taxpayers
so for example if you were to have an
annual wealth tax that taxed all wealth
above 10 million pounds that would be
taxing the top 22 000 people in the
country and that would raise at a rate
of say one percent it would raise about
10 billion pounds so that'll be enough
for example to send every household a
check for more than 400 pounds
of course this money isn't free
somebody has to pay it and some would
say the rich are taxed enough already
to look at the uk and say wealth is is
under tax relative to income i think it
is completely wrong we've already had a
jolly good go at the rich over the last
couple of decades and we've had an
excellent go at the moderately rich as
well
but others disagree like gary stevenson
the problem is the taxes that we have
don't really beat wealth because they're
all tax on income and some rich people
pay extremely low rates on their incomes
from their wealth and so just with
income taxes
the tax burden on these very wealthy
individuals might be
minimal and so say you're a billionaire
and you never sell your shares you're
never going to be subject to capital
gains taxes say your company doesn't
distribute dividends you're not going to
be paying dividend taxes on your
dividend income
and so obviously a wealth tax might be a
way of taxing potentially very wealthy
people
i think there are three ways you could
respond to the fact that a wealth tax
could raise serious amounts of money one
is to question the need for that extra
government revenue ultimately a
political judgment for each of us
another is to say that some countries
have relatively low tax burdens others
have very high ones so the wealth tax
question depends on which country we're
talking about
but the third response is to consider a
wealth tax not as a policy to raise more
government revenue but to raise the same
amount of revenue in smarter ways
a wealth tax could be used to reduce
taxes on work
it's not the riches paying the most tax
it's not it's the it's the people who
work you pay the most tax a wealth tax
could also replace other taxes on
capital that could in theory encourage
better and more productive investments a
wealth tax
is
levied
irrespective
of
the returns that your assets generate so
the last thing that you want when you
have a wealth tax
is
to have assets that don't generate any
returns or that generate
really small returns because you'll be
taxed anyway so that should encourage
you to invest in more you know in higher
yielding more productive assets
so here's a proposal that i think could
win over some skeptics
to introduce a wealth tax specifically
to lower or eliminate other taxes
if they believe that that's what would
happen
would i be happy with a say 1 annual
wealth tax if other taxes were reduced
or removed well that would be a
perfectly reasonable conversation but
i've you know i've been in this business
a long time now and so have you and i
have never
seen attacks abolished not once ever
now if you think that public spending
needs to go up to pay for better schools
or hospitals or roads then this is fine
so long as you can be sure that a wealth
tax will actually bring in the expected
extra money
for here we come to the pragmatic
objections to wealth taxes because in
practice they have not always worked as
advertised
they didn't raise that much revenue in
the countries that had them
because there are so many
assets benefiting from either full
exemptions or
other forms of preferential tax
treatment and often those were the
assets that were predominantly held by
the wealthiest people and so that means
that an increase in the value of
household wealth doesn't necessarily
translate in an increase in wealth tax
revenues and the problem hasn't just
been about exempting some assets
typically your home or more unusual
assets like artwork
it is also about avoidance and evasion
it was relatively easy
um to avoid and evade wealth taxes in a
lot of countries
which led to in france we would say the
wealth tax was the tax on the
millionaires not billionaires you know
what i think these guys would pay it if
they felt no one else was avoiding it
the problem is you create a situation
where it's easy to avoid and then it
becomes a choice and then you're a rich
guy and all the other guys you work with
are avoiding it and then their kids are
going to go to better schools than your
kids and their kids are going to have
nice houses than your kids because you
chose to pay tax
there's another common criticism
that many people with property wealth
don't have the cash to pay a wealth tax
if you live in your house it doesn't
give you a return it doesn't give you
income that you can use to then pay the
tax and so we always give this example
of you know the retiree in a house that
uh has tripled in value in the last 30
years and they're faced with the wealth
tax it's incredibly cruel very unkind to
people who hold wealth
and are unable to come up with cash
without making very significant changes
to their lifestyle well there are
solutions you can have tax deferrals you
can have tax payment in installments
also solutions like imposing a tax cap
limiting the total amount of tax that
you owe as a share of your income
another practical objection is that
wealth is really hard to value
so how do you value a private company
how do you value land how do you value a
picture how do you value the things that
make up wealth this is an
extraordinarily intense admin effort we
have to be put into this and i think
there is some merit to that that's why i
think you wouldn't want to have a wealth
tax that covers huge shares of the
population covers you know 10 or
something firstly it's administratively
easier because there's just a small
number of them the other point is that
they're typically people who are wealthy
enough that actually they have other
people managing their money for them
already where they already have some
process going on and so actually it's
not that hard for them usually to get
some kind of value and to have some
discussion about where those values come
from the idea that your personal
belongings should somehow be catalogued
and valued by the state i think is very
intrusive
in any case the poor design of many
actual wealth taxes was the main reason
why they were eventually abolished so
what would a well-designed wealth tax
look like you have to capture all kinds
of wealth and if you're worries that
you're capturing kind of people who are
kind of too ordinary for what you're
trying to go for you need to set the
threshold higher not exempt certain
asset classes not take out businesses or
not take out pensions or not take out
houses the people who are the problem
it's not the people with one million
pounds it's a people with 100 million
pounds i'd be more than happy to exclude
people with wealth of one two three
million pounds if that meant that we got
the people who are rich and there's a
need to look at
structures that may be used by
individuals
to circumvent wealth taxes
like trusts or foundations or other
similar structures
that that may be used i think that is an
important element
and then continuing efforts on i was
saying we made great progress on
preventing offshore tax division we need
to continue working on that because that
is a prerequisite to have
well-functioning
wealth taxes
[Music]
politics means that no tax will ever
live up to theoretical perfection but
even less than perfect wealth taxes are
not doomed to fail
we know this because some countries have
kept them for decades if not centuries
switzerland and
norway they're not perfect they also
suffer from exemptions and loopholes
but they do seem sustainable both
economically and politically these are
after all two of the world's most
successful economies in both countries
the wealth tax substitutes for other
taxes inheritance tax has been
eliminated in norway switzerland
strictly limits both inheritance tax and
capital gains tax
and the swiss wealth tax alone
contributes as much as four percent of
total tax revenue
there's another practical objection to
address
wouldn't the wealth tax just drive the
wealthy away
if people have to pay a tax and they do
not have the income to pay that tax
then they will find they find ways not
to pay it or b change their behavior in
order to produce the money to pay it it
comes a point when you have to think
well you might they just moved to
portugal
what does the evidence say
there was definitely anecdotal evidence
of
people leaving
countries with wealth taxes
and usually they were very high profile
cases and quite vocal about it so think
about gerhard pardue in france another
case that cited is the founder of
ikea and sweden for example and so
there's definitely anecdotal evidence
but we're still missing solid evidence
on
let's say the scale of the issue
so do the wealthy move away to avoid
wealth taxes
well the swiss and norwegian experiences
suggest not both have more millionaires
per capita than all the g7 countries so
to be fair switzerland does have a
lighter system for foreign tax exams
anyway there are things governments can
do when u.s presidential hopeful
elizabeth warren proposed a wealth tax
her advisors outlined a large one-off
exit levy that would apply when someone
moved their wealth out of the tax
even those who move away will have to
leave some assets behind and those can
be taxed
i like the term wealth creating sort of
conceptual like they're gandalf or
something they come with their magic and
they create wealth in society um and we
imagine them like they've got a big bag
of cash that they can just magic off to
the cayman islands these people are rich
because they own our houses they own our
mortgages you know what i mean they own
ours they own our skyscrapers and they
can leave the stuff is still here the
government knows that if we actually
wanted to tax these people based on the
assets which are here and cannot be
moved we can do it but the government
chooses not to do it
but even if they stay could a wealth tax
not discourage the wealthy from saving
and investing could the wealth creators
just stop creating wealth
the studies that are out there show that
the impact on savings on wealth
accumulation are limited and they find
stronger impacts on
how people report their wealth on tax
avoidance and on tax division
even my wealth tax skeptic colleague
agrees with that
humans are natural improvers barters
accumulators etc it's a natural instinct
people are not going to stop attempting
to accumulate but they may certainly
attempt to avoid or evade anyone
removing any of that accumulated wealth
from them
all of this taken together suggests to
me that a wealth tax doesn't have to be
as impractical or as punitive as it's
sometimes made out to be
but it's also not yet obvious what a
wealth tax achieves that we can't do
better and simpler by fixing the taxes
we already have
you might want to look at your existing
instruments first so your capital gains
taxes your inheritance and gift taxes
because there's so much scope
to reform those taxes
start with that because you can go a
long way towards raising revenue from
the wealthiest households and narrowing
wealth gaps
there is one thing however that a wealth
tax can do more forcefully than any
other tax
at the point that enough people are
concerned that wealth inequality at the
very top end is rising and that's
something they want to do something
about that's the point in which it's
clear that none of the alternatives will
work and that's the point i think in
which we'll see people actually passing
an annual house
if you think inequality has become
dangerously high and has to be reduced a
smart wealth tax is the quickest and
simplest way to do that the ones who are
smart they realize that
being rich personally is not worth
destroying your society and
that needs it needs outflows from the
rich to be enormously more to be really
honestly enormously more there's no
other way to say it
so what have i learned from these
conversations about annual wealth taxes
well if well designed it would
definitely reduce wealth inequality
and it could very well encourage more
productive investment
but it would have to be very carefully
structured
both to overcome the very real practical
challenges and the design flaws that are
made countries abandon wealth taxes in
the past
above all
it could raise very significant amounts
of revenue
and at a time of slowing growth and
pressured public finances
that is an advantage policymakers cannot
afford to ignore
[Music]
and finally we'd love to hear what you
think so please share your comments
[Music]
you